melb reveals she's checking herself into  rehab for alcohol and sex addiction the  43 year old America's Got Talent judge  released a statement to the Sun on  Sunday explaining her reasoning behind  getting help following her divorce from  Stephen Belafonte and her father's death  quote I've been working with a writer on  my book brutally honest and it has been  unbelievably traumatic reliving an  emotionally abusive relationship and  confronting so many massive issues in my  life sometimes it is too hard to cope  with all the emotions I feel adding the  problem has never been about sex or  alcohol it is underneath all that I am  fully aware I have been at a crisis  point  no one knows myself better than I do but  I am dealing with it Mel also revealed  she'll be seeking treatment next month  in the UK because she is quote very very  British and knows that will work best  for her et has reached out to Mel B's  rep for comment  you